Russia just pulled out of the last
nuclear arms treaty with the U.S which
means a new nuclear arms race may have
just begun and that could have some
serious consequences for the West this
Arms Treaty put a cap on the number of
nuclear weapons the U.S and Russia can
deploy but now that Russia is pulling
out of that treaty all bets are off from
now on Russia can do whatever they want
with their nuclear weapons Putin could
literally double Russia's nuclear
warheads without telling anyone he can
test them and position them however he
pleases and no one will know what he's
up to and there's a good reason why he's
playing that card now see the West
support for Ukraine has Putin fuming
some even say he feels cornered so now
he's considering every option on the
table